the gyro can experience there's so much
content right now has never never been a
time where this think about what a
better time it is entertainment wise to
be quarantined I'll think if we're
quarantine the nine be oh my god you'd
be [ __ ]
what are you know watch back in those
blockbuster days you can't go the
blockbusters his clothes I think you do
you know I was having a conversation
with my wife about this last night and
she's like I think theaters are done and
I'm like I brought up to him just before
this what Dave small potential cuz there
are lots of different companies that
could do it
they could maybe open up to like maybe
fifty people and you just separate it by
two chairs or something maybe that's a
movie yeah I think they think movie
theaters are done too in that Apple TV
has opened up the door during this
quarantine to get new movies and
controls hits Friday my sons crunk is
[ __ ] for it they had a bunch of new
movies that were supposed to come out in
the movie James Bond got pushed back to
November I don't think they should push
them back I think that's a mistake
I think they should release those
[ __ ] and make all their money listen
but still everyone is watching now
everyone if they come out with a badass
James Bond film we'd be all over and
everybody text their friend dude this
[ __ ] new James Bond movies the [ __ ]
Daniel Craig better be James Bond is EJ
he was any other I think is the new DB
eleven in it listen if you're gonna have
a female James Bond or whatever nonsense
you gonna do now [ __ ] out of my face
please make it double oh nine yeah blow
eight double-oh-seven son keep Jay
Daniel Craig is the greatest James Bond
of all time better than Sean Connery
he's the best 100 percent all of them
can eat [ __ ] [ __ ] no disrespect sir
Thomas JPEGs the only one I believe I
don't believe he's really kicking
anybody's ass I believe Daniel Craig is
[ __ ] people others I believe he's
shooting people he's the only one I
believe the only one that means a lot
Pierce Brosnan
how dare you wonderful man that's
wonderful man I don't he was Goldeneye
the greatest game of all time I don't
believe him as amazing actor he's a
beautiful man I don't believe him as a
murderess you're
English [ __ ] spy characters they
believe Daniel Craig [ __ ] people up
come on son the guy on the right is the
real deal he's got out like a face that
looks like he's been punched 150 times
right he's a man's man I'll do the
original far left come on son
eat some [ __ ] eat it eat it there's one
guy Daniel Craig you know eat [ __ ] elbow
was gonna be bond I'll buy that I'd buy
that really I don't care if bonds black
its but he has to be a bad [ __ ]
and a Juris elbows a legitimate bad
[ __ ] i man have you ever heard
of who's the guy who does the Trevor
knows bit on a black James Bond no it's
so [ __ ] funny why don't they look
Trevor no he talked about it it's like
where's he gonna hide he has a hole but
it's so [ __ ] good that's fun yeah
Daniel Craig is it's right now as of
right now he's the best ever he's the
only one I believe but I believe if they
had a similar movie with Idris Elba I
believe that too I'd buy that guys had a
legit Muay Thai fight as a professional
actor any movie started a legit Muay
Thai fight yeah train guy was paid off
to take a fall but you know I hear you I
like yeah that's the rumor the romance
the room without so I would say I think
the opponent came out was like you know
they paid me ticket fall right but if
that beautiful man beat my ass I
probably say that to me to yourself you
might have to tell people you took a
fall I don't believe you you took a fall
first of all if you say you took a fall
you might be even telling the truth but
you're the type of person that's willing
to take a fall so I can never believe
yeah I know you're not that many people
because people like Anthony Smith that
won't win the World title vs. John Jones
by disqualification because they have
character and then there's people who
take dives so if you're the type of
people who takes a dive how am I gonna
believe you anyways [ __ ] how am I gonna
believe you anyway I think it just Alba
[ __ ] you up probably I think I think
scar [ __ ] you up
I think double-o ate [ __ ] you wait let
me say I think he [ __ ] you up you
don't like it
[Applause]